[Music]
it's your facial hair situation mom
Ilana it's like it's your mom beautiful
one is life is so funny
[Music]
what has broad city meant to you it's my
it's my friends it's me and my friend
Becky and I friend Ally my friend
Chelsea like it's it's all of us just
like sitting around like smoking weed or
talking about jumbo or the patriarchy I
think the reason I love broad city so
much is because it's like your own life
just exaggerated if you guys ran the
show if you ran broad city
how would you end its final season
honestly I just hope Abbi and Ilana get
married did you mention that you
FaceTime with your friend to watch broad
city or call them yeah I do
my best friend and I used to live in the
same town we went to college together in
Boston so what we do is we'd be in bed a
lot of the time like Alana and Abby turn
on the TV show and we'll FaceTime or
call one another so we can still watch
it together are you more of an Abby or
an Alana and why I'm definitely more an
Abby I'm not as bold as Alana she's
really amazingly out there though for me
but I guess not so sorry sorry to do
this yeah we're having a little bit of a
lighting issue in the back there I'm
having a look at the shadow there
[Music]
oh yeah - - that's it
test here
[Music]
yeah we're just kidding it's us okay
Jesus that was I so just like I'm so
professional oh my god we were really
nervous oh my god feel my heart I like
really like we were losing our minds
we're due guys the ones that were over
there the whole time yeah yeah show me
to tell
[Music]
frosty Liang frost van I can leave now I
can die 2019 the rest of its in effect
[Music]